Unfortunately,
we can't be together
as long as you think that way.
I think it's best if we
try this again another time.
Now get out of here.
No.
What?
This is the Shaman King's commune!
My will is everything in this world!
I can't leave.
Not until I do something about you.
It can't be!
You also have the Shaman King's power?
Not just him.
Tao Ren!
I'm here too.
Horokeu Usui!
And us!
Joco McDonnell!
Lyserg Diethel!
We're in the afterlife,
so you've got the seeing version of me!
I see.
The Five Grand Elemental Spirits.
You're able to enter this place
because you have the power of those
who make up the Great Spirit!
More or less.
But we only obtained them after we
were already inside the Great Spirit.
Thanks to you killing everyone!
Now, since we're here,
want a taste of our power?
Over Soul!
Spirit of Thunder!
Gather and blot out the heavens,
black cumulonimbus clouds!
Nine Dragon Exploding Thunder!
You killed us all,
knowing this would happen, didn't you?
Over Soul! Spirit of Rain!
Let the downpour begin!
Have some of this!
Porowaok Ererupus Shinupuri!
You can't say you didn't have this coming!
Over Soul!
Spirit of Wind!
The name comes from a wind god…
Now, blow it all away,
God Breath Hurricane!
Over Soul! Spirit of Fire!
Not even the flames of hell
are hot enough
for a spoiled brat like you!
Take this!
Magma Uppercut!
Amazing…